ils ne sont que très rarement ouvert à la presse
par crainte d'espionnage industriel la visite des
ateliers loir et chérien de la célèbre marque
de sacs à main vuitton était donc très attendu
parmi les 18 sites français deux sont à vendôme
inauguration en grande pompe aujourd'hui avec
les grands patrons du groupe lvmh et bruno
le maire -ministre de l'économie et de la
relance reportage sur place d'hélène chapelet à
droite l'homme le plus riche de france à gauche
le ministre de l'économie pourtant pas question
de parler de gros sous à l'inauguration des deux
ateliers vuitton implanté en loir et cher ici
c'est l'excellence française que l'on souhaite
mettre en valeur et l'ancrage local au coeur des
territoires dans le vendômois le maroquinier de
luxe a déjà recruté 200 personnes il souhaite à
terme créer 500 emplois auparavant christ elle
était assistante maternelle elle est en formation
depuis novembre dernier pour intégrer de manière
définitive l'effectif vuitton c'est toujours
d'un attrait pour les activités manuelles avec
mes enfants dans mon ancien métier quand j'étais
assistant pat hamel donc mon agenda ne prévoyait
pas que je termine maroquinière celle du thon
mais j'ai cette chance et c'est incroyable en
fait de pouvoir apprendre si rapidement des gestes
qui sont ancestraux comme ça c'est très intense
mais c'est ce que du bonheur la majorité de ses
salariés n'avaient jamais touché une aiguille
avant d'entrer chez vuitton tous ont été formés en
interne à l'école des savoir-faire 12 mois minimum
pour apprendre à travailler les cuirs exotiques
comme le piton le lézard ou l'alligator on va
apprendre déjà l'utilisation de nos machines à
coudre ou tout simplement toutes les spécificités
qui vont aller qui vont aller de pair avec
notre matière exotiques si donc c'est donc un
savoir-faire très particulier toutes les matières
différentes vont s'approcher de façon différente
on apprendra donc à les manipuler avec le temps
en fonction de leur réaction après et direction
vendôme et le quartier rochambeau c'est là que
le deuxième atelier vuitton s'est installée
l'ancien bâtiment classé a été totalement et
pour accueillir un atelier de fabrication de
sacs à main si tous les postes ne sont pas encore
pourvus le patron a des arguments convaincants
pour trouver de la main d'oeuvre au delà du
salaire vous avez un intéressement résultat
qui peut aller michael jusqu'à 10 mois 18 mois
de salaire par an mais donc chez vuitton quand
on entre chez vuitton on a envie de rester en
2021 le numéro un mondial du luxe lvmh a réalisé
un bénéfice record de 12 milliards d'euros un
résultat supérieur à ceux réalisés avant la
pandémie 30 milliards d'euros de ventes ont été
réalisées grâce à la mode et à la maroquinerie